voici david crucia ni alias david body
un mètre soixante dix huit 108 kg 6 fois
par semaine et deux fois par jour il
sculpte son corps et repousser le vote
régulier c'est faut être assidu il faut
avoir détermination entre l'alimentation
et l'entraînement c'est une synergie et
avec c'est que comme ça qu'on peut
progresser quoi il faut qu'on se fasse
mal niveau 1 niveau alimentation et
entraînement au départ la musculation
était un loisir puis david est devenu
body builder à 29 ans il reprend la
compétition et vient d'ailleurs de
terminer quatrièmes au top de colmar
compétition culturiste de référence en
france maintenant je me prépare pour une
compétition le 9 juillet c'est un
régional c'est une régionale pour une
qualification professionnelle peut-être
plus tard
de la rigueur dans le travail mais aussi
dans l'alimentation pour être aussi
affûté david s'impose un régime strict
où aucun écart n'est tolérée en période
de seiche il peut avaler jusqu'à sept
mille calories par jour avec plusieurs
compléments alimentaires tous les
aliments tout tout ça ils sont pesées
donc moi je pèse mon poulet ma viande
mon smith tech mûri mais pas tu as tout
est pesé sarin de prendre des
compléments
du comment dire en poudre quant à des
protéines des baissés à tout ça sans une
alimentation strictes à côté ça sert à
rien il partage aussi son corps sur les
réseaux sociaux depuis le confinement
david est devenu influenceurs et atteint
un million et demi d'abonnés sur steam
doc il fait jusqu'à six vidéos par jour
découvert petite toque et du coup je me
suis dit bon bah il y avait une trêve
d'une traîne c'est un sont tendances du
moment j'ai j'avais une idée avec mon
chien tout simplement du coup j'ai fait
cette reine avec mon chien et en 48
heures jeudi l'abonné du coup je me suis
dit ben pourquoi pas continuer pas à
terme david aimerait développer cette
activité pour pouvoir vivre uniquement
grâce aux réseaux sociaux et percer dans
le milieu du pot dit building